Oh
so for human beings existential angst
stems from the fact that we are
creatures of meaning right we are
creatures of purpose we are creatures of
myth right we want to feel like there is
a destiny to our lives like there is a
reason why we're here right and we try
to address this existential itch this
agitation through the creation of
beautiful stories beautiful myths right
we've created narrative threads
religions systems of thought that have
placed the body mind in a larger context
that have made us feel like we are part
of something greater than ourselves
this is hugely important but what are we
alternately when you break it down when
you shatter the myths what are we left
with
right and they let a great quote
recently that said that actually we are
dead stars looking back at our selves
and then when you consider we look upon
the heavens we have the Hubble Space
Telescope blasting new tunnels between
the mind and the other is Russ Anderson
says and we look back right and we are
the remnants of those stars that died
right the periodic table of the elements
all of it was manufactured in the
furnaces of stars so we are dead stars
looking back in ourselves right I mean
this idea is just astonishing we are we
are poetry we are we are cosmic poetry
if that's not enough the story to help
you get up of get up in the morning then
and I don't know what
you